l'économique et aujourd'hui notre invité
mais l'invité principal de cette antenne
de midi aujourd'hui c'est sylvia kristel
quand la victime devient une star c'est
un peu ce qui est arrivé à sylvia
kristel après l'énorme succès des
manuels le film érotique par excellence
et qui constitue l'un des plus grands
succès de l'histoire du cinéma avec plus
de 100 millions de spectateurs
une image qui colle à la peau de sylvia
kristel même si elles déploient des
trésors d'imagination pour faire savoir
qu'elle est plutôt d'un tempérament
fleur bleue voire romantique
aujourd'hui l'amant de lady chatterley
reconstitue le tandem sylvia kristel
juste chacun avec emmanuel ils faisaient
tous les deux leurs premiers pas au
cinéma avec la réussite que l'on sait
sylvia kristel est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui encore d'être
prisonnière débat noël manuel c'était
tellement fort quand même pas que c'est
difficile de s'en sortir mais je me suis
calmé aux états unis on a déclaré sept
films succès donc c'est une image mais
il vient christiane emmanuel c'était un
hasard où il est absolument jouer ce
rôle eu ce rôle vous passionnait
passionnés bon je ne sais pas comment
dire ça c'est à cet endroit là mais la
za voudrait que juste m'a choisi pour
cette horreur les attaquants même
qu'elles cherchent la voie que toutes
les comédiennes que vous aviez présenté
était malade ce jour là c'est pas des
gens c'est vrai que à chacun un metteur
en scène pas connu en france demande
avec des comédiens connus de faire un
film érotique à l'époque c'était j'étais
le diable diplomates ils ont eu des
grandes m'avait dit o matic et la fin de
cuges q thomas en langue pour trouver
sur 6 mais ça se passait en quelle année
justement pas ce comptage à remonter 74
ans 74 était très difficile de trouver
une comédienne qui accepte de tourner ce
genre d'aurillac à l'époque l'érotisme
était vraiment banny partout puisque on
peut dire aussi qu'il faut être modeste
succès les manuels aussi a été due à la
libération de la censure et qu'on est en
fait le premier film érotique je crois
que on est les premiers sortis donc on a
bénéficié de cet énorme succès à cause
de ça on en parlait tout à l'heure mais
même si les officiels pourquoi vous avez
vous accepté de jouer ce rôle vous
cherchez un rôle à l'époque oui mais
parlait pas français
très bien alors je me suis pas tout à
fait réaliser jusqu'à quel point ça
allait partir mais j'avais surtout
confiance en juste qui à mon avis était
l'artiste avec l'impossibilité d'être
banal au vulgaire donc c'était pour moi
une grande chance le premier rôle de
tout cela nous parlerons donc tout à
l'heure mais comme la coutume le veut si
la crise elle vous allez avec nous
participer et suivre l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui on va tout de suite
commencé avec la météo et les prévisions
d'alain gillot pétré